いやぁ皆さんこんにちははじめ履かせたやっぱりさあ皆どのようにこのつず過ごして
いるかな
バードしっかり家で遊んでいる人も多いだろう今日私が話したいの最近ろ書と灯台天気
皆外得るために思うよね今の的外出るとあー緑びっしょり
うんざりだよねぇもう僕は外で遊びたいた
相当で遊んでる砂遊び読書左右
なのでばあちゃんはさずまり女では去っ楚辺ない
残念だペンは僕が思いついたんだよぜひエアーで遊ぶがどうなるだろうか
室内さんを違うと大変なことになるぞポーズももちろんアピールしみんなパワー確定
chou んだードンヨプしましょそうぞ砂マヨプラウドニュースなうもつくような
クレジット
ね僕は絶対しないそこで忘却簡単はしないようなんじゃないの
ふーん俺は買うことによって室内でも簡単に水の地域にはできない砂遊びで言うんじゃ
ないかなと思って見たけれこれ
室内用の砂キネティックサンド100キログラム分買ってしまった
あっはの
なんか英語っぽい感じて
おもしろいバグ男性ですというわけで最近雨がひどくて外で遊べない
砂遊びもできないけど僕ちん砂遊びしたいそんなとこに枚日つきました室内用夏菜と
いうものを発見しましたこちら
キネティックサンド分なんかしてねーほんとでは乗る見たことあるんですよねなんか
室内寄せなんですよねこれ1ハンマーに動きが入ってて20キロ買いましたので合計
100球によっている
負けてきますね
うわぁ凄いめっちゃ入ってるうわーめっちゃ見たことある
恋ザラスに売り勝ちほらみてくれ海外から取り入れた価値バッチリだろヘレティック
サンド室内用お砂遊び
今までに経験したことがない不思議な砂の感触に癒されますもちろん色々作る楽しみも
絶対に水を混ぜないでくださいそれ形でやっぱ外じゃ遊べないですよねこの砂やもう
これ室内用のお砂遊び
書いてあることは家の中だったらこれぶちまけてもいいんですよ
何か勘違いする気がするけどなんか本当にいる中で勝ちの砂を果て入れても砂がつくっ
てみたとってみたいなことしようと思ったんだかそれが2円沿い炎上しちゃいそうなの
で室内ようなそんなで遊んでいたいと思いますあけてみましょういや俺はこれでも抵抗
あるけどね結構
円高で砂やなよだって女
じゃ普通にこの子達遊んでるもんでやなぁわーまあ
ガッツリスナーさんこれ大丈夫でめっちゃだの砂かんだけど
思う受けます
んわーまあなんかトロドロップしてるわーなんかとろとろってするけど砂ですねまぁ
昼間の質なんだこれははや武器もっちー
たらすごいねほんとなんかでも室内用っていうだけあってめっちゃまとまるやすごい
市郡してくれるでしょうかめちゃくちゃ綺麗なきめ細かい海の砂浜って感じです何か
ほんと足とか振ると気持ちよさそう
これ100件ありますというわけで勝手じゃなく魂は生姜ね人生で一度はやってみたら
ということを得安中に砂場を作りたいと思います室内で様の作ったからあんなにも風の
日も一生生の遊びていきますからこれ台でも言ってないんでちょっとウチの社員さんが
どういう反応をするかわかんないんですけどもとりあえず家の日陰を全部砂場にして絶
気持ちいいと思う結構みんな喜ぶと思うんですけどちょっと1回
部屋の地面砂場にしてみたいと思いますねでもいい
みんなお金ねーかな
入った
愛的にちょっと百鬼の運ぶ力はないんで10キロずつ向こうに運んでいきましょう
俺のイメージしてばもうその部屋の床全部砂にしたインド砂場だから言われたっけ
女良だと思うんですよねなぜに出てきますぅはもう
がちですなじゃあ待ってライン創部からねこれなんで使えるんかなぁ
だってキッズ部だからなよとかモーゼなら今っっ
ああああああ
よしズッキを入れましたん
覆い涙過ごしもっちーなホレス何よりなんだろ時過ぎな観測縦にちゃんと付くな
さあエビみんなしっかり見ドッキこれがキネティックサンド絶景の部分ですや結構多い
し強みてぺさんの特徴を触ってると動くはなんかぼとぼととってちょっと不思議なが
まとまりがある砂って感じですねえペンなの
10往復かー
運びます
[音楽]
見えません
おおおおっ
th よししています
wh
入っていた
ん
やって15切れちゃったあんま
しています
をし par
ええええええこれ
ええええええええええええ
me
持っています
[音楽]
はいしんどいあの100系ルアー昆布の本当につらかったですというわけでツアー
こんなんですけどもそこが固まりとからねもうちょっと鳴らしてみます
[音楽]
うわーん
六騎士
[音楽]
ん
ないというふうに完成しましたすれば音が出るかいやもう完全に砂浜でしょこれこれ
なんか探したんですよねそれがすごい気持ちというか触り心地がいいんですよねや
けっこう広いすねー
ぜんじされ不安なくこのただに2巻でも見つめている
そんながつくってみますかすごいすごいすごい2にそういうことができちゃう
普通に遊ぶですよこれもまあこれもすげーする8歳になるですよこれ結構普通に何でも
付けれ
こうやったらほらもうすぐ単語とを作れます
これはいい
バッグランス
[笑い]
家ですこれ家でこれできるのすごくないですかいやー鈴にすげーよ
レフティアナた奴が集めてさカウパーシーンだったら
[音楽]
僕ですっ
半くらいでそこそこ満喫したところであのこれ誰も知らないわけです僕いいが今から家
に来るメンバーとかも
隣で寝てる奴が今何も知らないんで日た瞬間どういう反応するのかちょっと見てみよう
と思いますしてこれだったらいいじゃじゃないですか
いやいやかテンション上がるかわかんないけどどういう感じなんだろちょっと見て
みようと思いますでは
ん
voodoo
を1人制
えっ
結構行ったんですよねっ
もうなんじゃこれ
粘土を
遠藤ですか
なーまん
えええ
なにこれすなはま砂場かきなこかと思った
[音楽]
voodoo
あっちょ